Hãy hãy làm tháng 12 hành hành hành hủ trong 3 mâm, một người đàn ông năm sau tùy, sống ở miếng bác i t lì,
bí đưa chá vì hó trang thành miếng mẹ đã qua đời vào năm 12 hành hành hủ trong 3 mẹ, để tức tục nữu của bà.
Thế vì báo tín này đã qua đời vào hành hủ ngày dấu thì tế bà trong nhà, rồi hàng tháng đổi tóc ra, trong điểm,
đời tương thái giống mẹ để tự đựa địa đường lưu.
Một việc đứa phát hiện khi người này cải trang thành mẹ để tự giá hạn thay cân cứ tải văn phòng của đồng đứa phương.
Tại đây, cuộc bà này thì thỏng nói sọng đàn ông khiến một nhân viên hộ đồng ý ngờ,
sau khi quán sát ký, nhân viên này là tức báo tín cho kánh sát,
giờ trước sau đó mở của đi chá, khám sát nhàng người đàn ông và phát hiện thi thể người mẹ đã hóa được số trộng hoặc sạm.
Đừng biết, người đàn ông này là Ita Thất nghiệp có tuy nhất năm 2018,
nhưng người đừng có mẹ và sự hiểu bá rất đồng sát.